مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
رياض نبداها بالعناوي
لمواجهه الصين وروسيا
تكشف عن توجه واشنطن لتعزيز ترسانتها في
اسيا اوروبا
لقاء سعودي ايراني مرتقب وامير عبد الهيان
يؤكد حرصه طهران على تطوير العلاقات مع
الرياض
اول ايام رمضان خطه تشغيليه ضخمه في مكه
المكرمه 107 الاف معتمر طاقه الحرم فيسع
في الرابعه
حدثت شاب في الرياض تعيد التحذيرات للواجه
ادمان سريع والتعافي منه اعرضه صعبه
على عوده مسلسل طاش ما طاش ثنائيه القصبي
والسدحان تعود بعد 11 عاما من الانقطاع
قال مسؤولون امريكيون لصحيفه ان الولايات
المتحده سترسل طائرات هجوميه
متقادمه من طراز اي 10 لتحل محل طائرات
مقاتله اكثر تطورا في الشرق الاوسط وذلك
كجزء من جهود البنتاجون لنقل المزيد من
المقاتلات الحديثه الى المحيط الهادئ
واوروبا لردع الصين وروسيا واضاف
المسؤولون الامريكيون للصحيفه ان عمليه
نقل طائرات اي 10 المقرر اجراؤها في ابريل
جزء من خطه اوسع تدعو ايضا الى الاحتفاظ
بقوات بحريه وبريه محدوده في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط والتركيز على مواجهه نفوذ الصين
وروسيا وانه بموجب الخطه الجديده سيتمركز
سيربون من طائرات اي 10 في المنطقه الى
جانب سربين من طائره اف 15
و 8 بطاريات باتريوت للدفاع الجوي
من القاهره ينضم الينا الدكتور محمد
الزيات مستشار المركز المصري للفكر
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه الدكتور محمد اهلا
وسهلا بك كل عام وانت بخير اولا دكتور
لماذا الان تريد امريكا استبدال الطائرات
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وبعض قطع الاسلحه
بطائرات قديمه ماذا يعني ذلك في مستقبل
الصراع مع روسيا والصين
تحياتي اولا استاذ خالد وكل سنه وحضرتك
والمشاهدين بخير هناك عدد من الملاحظات
الاوليه على هذا الخبر يعني الكم من
الاسلحه التي ذكر لا ينقل او الطائرات
ونوعياتها وصواريخ الباتروت لا تمثل نقل
استراتيجيه في الحضور العسكري الامريكي
بمنطقه الشرق الاوسط فالحضور العسكري
الامريكي في الشرق الاوسط ليس فقط في
القواعد العسكريه ولكن هناك حاملات طائرات
عليها احدث الطائرات الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه
النقطه الثانيه ان هناك فعلا تغيير في
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه الامريكيه او
السردجات الدفاعيه الامريكيه تركز على
الصين بالدرجه الاولى وعلى نقل وتكثيف
الحضور العسكري في بحر الصين الجنوبي وفي
التقدير ان الاسلحه التي سوف تنقل ربما
تكون معنيه بالقاعده الجديده او الحضور
العسكري الجديد الامريكي في الفلبين
والتحالفات العسكريه التي تنشا سواء مع
استراليا او مع الدول الموجوده هناك
وعمليه تسليح اليابان كل هذه الامور اصبحت
تحدد ان الاطار العام للاستراتيجيه
العسكريه الامريكيه خلال العقد القادم
ستكون كيفيه
تركيز او ردع او حصار القوه العسكريه
الصينيه المتكامله دكتور محمد انت تحدثت
عن نقاط كثيره وهي مهمه لكن اريد فقط ان
اشير الى ان مجافل
ان ذلك يعتبر جزء من خطه اوسع تدعو ايضا
الاحتفاظ بقوه بحريه وبريه متواضعه في
منطقه
الشرق الاوسط في هذه الحاله الدكتور بدانا
نتحدث عن الامر هل هل هل امران مختلفان
يعني نفس الاستراتيجيه في مواجهه الصين
وفي التعامل معها هي ذاتها في التعامل مع
روسيا ام ان الامر يختلف
بالتاكيد هناك اختلاف في الاستراتيجيه في
التعامل مع روسيا والتعامل الصيني التعامل
مع روسيا اصبح محوره الان الحضور العسكري
في اوكرانيا وعمليه استنزاف القوات
العسكريه الروسيه في حرب مستمره لا يقدر
لها ان تقف قبل عام على الاقل هذا هو
الحصار والحصار يمتد من خلال نشر قوات
عسكريه في الدوائر المحيطه بروسيا واخرها
القاعده العسكريه العسكريه الامريكيه في
بولندا هذا هو الحضور المتزايد على هذا
النمط اما فيما يتعلق بالصين فهي المجرد
لحظ القوات العسكريه هي قوات رضع اولا ثم
استعداد لايات مواجهات عسكريه يمكن ان
تنشا بين الطرفين مستقبلا باعتبارها العدو
الرئيسي خلال الفتره القادمه لكن الملاحظه
استاذ خالد هي على هل تنسحب القوات
العسكريه الاستراتيجيه من الشرق الاوسط لا
اعتقد لانه الخليج والبحر الاحمر والبحيض
والمحيط الهندي وجزء من استراتيجيه
الدفاعيه الامريكيه للتعامل مع الصين يعني
تمركز ليس فقط في بحر الصين الجنوبي ولكن
في الدوائر الاستراتيجيه المحيطه بتلك
المنطقه لكن حتى داخل هذا الخبر كان هناك
تحذيرات من بعض الجنرالات الامريكيين من
تخفيض حجم التواجد الامريكي واستبدال هذه
الاسلحه من الطائرات الحديثه مثلا بطائرات
قديمه الاي 10 فان ذلك سيؤثر على مستقبل
الشرق الاوسط لان هذا الامر او هذا
التواجد لن يكون كافيا للتعامل مع حجم
التهديدات في المنطقه فهل تغير الامر الان
بالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه خاصه بعد
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني برعايه صينيه ام
حجم التهديدات بالفعل تناقص لم يعد يستوجب
كل هذا الحضور العسكري الامريكي
معظم هذه الامور تدخل في الاجابه على
السؤال يعني بالفعل هناك متغير هام للغايه
واستراتيجي هو
اتفاق او التفاهم السعودي الايراني غير من
استراتيجيه التعامل على مستوى المنطقه
ازال ما كان يمكن ان يسمى بانشاء تحالف
عسكري لمواجهه الصين واعاد المنطقه الى
نوع من الهدوء النقطه الثانيه ان هناك
تخفيف ان الوجود العسكري الامريكي منذ عده
سنوات مؤخرا سواء في الكويت بصوره اساسيه
او في العراق يعني ثم انه كان الوجود
العسكري الاستراتيجي في الشرق الاوسط كان
مرتبطا بحضور عسكري كبير في افغانستان
وبعد الانسحاب العسكري الامريكي من
افغانستان لم تعد هناك حاجه للتمركز في
الدوائر المحيطه به بنفس الصوره التي كانت
وبالتالي هل يمكن القول انه حتى هذا
التحرك الان يمنع
او يصعب من اي خطط لضرب ايران مستقبلا وهو
ما زالت تسر عليه او تتحدث عنه الكثير من
يعني القيادات الاسرائيليه على راسها
بنيامين نتنياه
هو مؤشر على ذلك بوضوح ويؤكد على وجود
تباين فيما يتعلق بالموقف الامريكي
والموقف الاسرائيلي من توجيه ضربه الى
ايران يعني
الانسحاب ربما كانت رساله ايضا في جانب
منها الى اسرائيل ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لن تشارك في ايه عمليه عسكريه
توجه الى ايران وربما كانت تفاهم السعودي
الايراني دافعا لايران تكون اكثر انضباطا
في التعامل وحتى تتجاوب مع التوجه العام
لتحقيق التهدئه والتوتر في المنطقه
الدكتور اخيرا يعني بهذا الامر هل يمكن
القول بانه حاله الصراع بين امريكا والصين
انتقلت اليوم من تنافس او المنافسه الى
مواجهه قد تاخذ يعني شكل عسكري وهل هذا
يعني بانه امريكا تنوي بالفعل التواجد
العسكري الرسمي بشكل مديد يعني
مستقبلا في في الصين او في منطقه النفود
الصيني نعم
هناك تحرك امريكي استراتيجي واضح المعالم
للاستعداد وليس للمواجهه الان لكن
الاستعداد للمواجهه مع الصين
والتحالفات التي تقيمها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في اسيا بصوره واضحه وعمليات
التسليح المكثفه سواء لاستراليا او
لليابان وهو امر غير مسبوق يؤكد هذا
المنحى بصوره كبيره ويؤكد ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحتى
استراتيجيه الامن القومي الامريكي الاخيره
حددت الصين باعتبارها اهم التحديات التي
تواجه الامن القومي او الامن القومي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولا العالم
الغربي شكرا جزيلا لك من القاهره الدكتور
محمد مجاهد مستشار المركز المصري للفكر
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
وتابع معكم الان هذه الصور المباشره من
العاصفه من العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس واخرى
كذلك من مدينه تيرين لتين تشهدان احتجاجات
متواصله ما يسمى بالخميس الاسود
وقد جاء ذلك ربما احتجاجا على حديث الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون عن قانون اصلاح
التقاعد لقى لقت هذه التصريحات ردود فعل
غاضبه وممدد وذلك بعد حديث للمره الاولى
له منذ اندلاع على احتجاجات بعد اصراره
على تطبيق اصلاح نظام التقاعد
ماكرون شدده على اهميه دخول هذا المشروع
لحيز التنفيذ بحلول نهايه العام معتبرا
بانه ضروري وذلك في مقابله تلفزيونيه
نشاهد الان هذه الاحتجاجات في الشوارع
الفرنسيه ما زالت وربما الاعداد ستزيد
كذلك خلال الساعات القادمه
وايضا هناك تجهيز من النقابات اليوم
لاضراب عام لتظاهرات في تحرك
وصفته وسائل الاعلام بانه الخميس الاسود
[موسيقى]
في التطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه ظهر الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلنسكي منطقه خيرسون
الجنوبيه البلاد التي تسيطر عليها روسيا
بشكل جزئي بعد ان كانت تسيطر عليها بعد
بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا وقبل ان تنسحب منها
بشكل جزئي اواخر العام الماضي
اكد نائب رئيس مجلس الامن رئيس الحزب
الحاكم في روسيا دي متري مدفي ان تنفيذ
قرار اعتقال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
غير ممكن عمليا ويعتبر اعلان حرب على
روسيا
علينا في البدايه ان نتفق على ان تنفيذ
القرار غير ممكن عمليا تخيلوا ان رئيسا
حاليا لدوله نوويه يصل الى المانيا مثلا
في زياره ثم يتم اعتقاله هذا يعتبر اعلان
حرب على روسيا وفي هذه الحاله ستقوم روسيا
بالرد عسكريا وستطير جميع الوسائل الممكنه
والصواريخ الى
مكتب المستشار وما الى ذلك
فقد اعلنت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا خروفان من المستحيل سيطرته
على عواقب الاشعاع المنبعث من استخدام
قذائف اليورانيوم المنظف في اوكرانيا كما
اشاره زخرفه في افاده صحفيه بان من
المستحيل ايضا على الدول المجاوره
السيطره على عواقب استخدام هذه الاسلحه
عندما تستخدم
قال وزير الخرجه
تتوقع ان يكون التحقيق في انفجارات خط
انابيب الغاز نردستري العمل الماضي شفافا
وذلك بعد ان اجره الدنمارك والمانيا
والسويد تحقيقاتها الخاصه في التفجيرات
شككتت موسكو او شكت مرارا وتكرارا من عدم
ابلاغها بنتائج التي توصلت اليها اذكر ان
روسيا وصفت الحادثه بانها عمل يعود الى
الارهاب الدولي في سبتمبر الماضي
رابعه بعد قليل
ايامي رمضان انطلاق اكتتاب خيري في
السعوديه لتامين المساكن للاسر المحتاجه
اهلا بكم من جديد اسبوعان مرت على اتفاق
العاشر من مارس 2023 الذي اعاد استئناف
العلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه برعايه صينيه
في احداث التطورات وزير الخارجات السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان اتصالا هاتفيا اليوم
بنظيره الايراني حسين امير عبداللهيان
اتفق فيه الوزيران على عقد لقاء ثنائي
قريبا لتمهيد الارضيه لاعاده فتح السفارات
والقنصليات بين البلدين وزير الخارجيات
الايرانيه كذا استعداد بلاده لتطوير
وتعزيز العلاقات مع الرياض وفقا لما نقلت
وكاله ايرنا الايرانيه الرسميه
اول ايام شهر رمضان ايضا بدات فيه عده
وجهات حكوميه بتنفيذ خطه تشغيليه ضخمه في
الحرم المكي تشمل تسهيل الطوافي 107,000
معتمر في الساعه الواحده وسطت التوقعات
بتدفق ملايين المعتمرين كما تضمنت ابرز
ملامح الخطه التشغيليه للحرم المكي
التعظيم المسارات لكبار السن وذوي الاعاقه
وتعقيم كامل المسجد الحرام عشر مرات يوميا
فضلا عن سنه الخدمات المقدمه
[موسيقى]
اعداد مليونيه من المعتمرين والمصلين
يستقبلها المسجد الحرام بعد ان اعلنت
رئاسه الشؤون الحرمين ان تشغيل الحرم
المكي بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه دون قيود
طوال شهر رمضان ويقابلها منظومه عمل موسع
[موسيقى]
هناك خطه مشتركه ابواب محدده لدخول المصلي
وابواب محدده لدخول المعتمر حتى يتم خروجه
من هذه الشعيره تقوم الرئاسه بما لديها من
ممكنات ومن مستهدفات في خطتها بعرض جميع
محاور هذه الخطه حتى يقوم قاصد بيت الله
الحرام باداء نسخه بكل بكل يسر وسهوله
وبكل طمانينه خصصت رئاسه الشؤون الحرمين
اثني عشر الف موظف وعامل بالمسجد الحرام
وهيات اربعه عشر مسارا خاصا لدخول وخروج
المعتمرين والمصلين الى جانب فتح كافه
التوسعات السعوديه الثلاث بالحرم المكي
وتوفير تسعه الاف عربه كهربائيه ومتحركه
للتسهيل على كبار السن وذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه اضافه الى تسخير التقنيات والذكاء
الاصطناعي رحله المعتمر ورحله
اكتملت جميع خدماته بمنظوماتها التكامليه
والارشاديه وغيرها بالتنسيق مع الجهات
الامنيه فيما يحقق الراحه لقاصدي بيت الله
الحرام تسعى الرئاسه من خلال كوادرها
البشريه المتفانيه بالخبرات التراكميه الى
وضع خطه تشغيليه مرنه لموسم رمضان هذا
العام مع الاخذ في الاعتبار لعوده اعداد
المعتمرين والمصلين الى ما قبل جائحه
فيروس كورونا من الحرم المكي سلطان السلمي
العربيه
[موسيقى]
من الحرام المكي ينضمرين مراسل العربيه
نصفين هاني مرحبا بك كل عام وانت بخير
هاني
اولدنا كلنا الصوره حيث تتواجد الان كيف
هي حركه المعتمرين في الحرم المكي الشريف
نعم اهلا بك خالد واهلا بمشاهدين قناه
العربيه وكل عام وانتم بخير اذا العربيه
وكاميرا العربيه ترصد حال المعتمرين هنا
من صحن
الطواف هو تحديدا
بالقرب جدا من الكعبه طبعا رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين
اوضحت في بيان لها بشكل رسمي ان هذا العام
سوف تكون اكبر خطه تشغيليه
في الحرم المكي خاصه ان نتحدث اليوم عن
خطه تشغيليه ليس فقط في تسخير الكوادر
البشريه وايضا ليس في ايضا الخدمات
المقدمه ولكن ايضا الخطه التشغيليه ايضا
من الناحيه الامنيه وكذلك من خلال
المسارات التي
خصصت لدخول المعتمرين وكذلك دخول بشكل
ترددي وايضا خروجهم بشكل ترددي من مسارات
وبوابات مختلفه طبعا اليوم نتحدث من خلال
هذه الخ التشغيليه هناك اكثر من 12 الف
كادر بشري بداوا بالفعل يوم امس بدخولهم
وايضا تسهيل مهمه دخول المعتمرين سواء
بالقرب ابن خارج
المسجد الحرام او ايضا في الساحات
الخارجيه ايضا نتحدث اليوم عن صحن المطافه
الذين الان نقوم بالطوافير مع المعتمرين
كي نرصد حركه المعتمرين وحركتهم سلسه
نتحدث عن انه يستطيع بطاقه استعابيه ان
يتحمل اكثر من 107 الاف معتمر خلال ساعه
بامكانهم الطواف دفعه واحده طبعا ايضا
عزيزي خالد من خلال البوابات ايضا نشاهد
هنا بعض اللافتات وبعض ايضا مسميات
البوابات باللغات مختلفه حتى تسهل عمليه
دخول وخروج المعتمرين بحسب لغاتهم اليوم
لدينا اكثر من 51 يعني اللغه او 51 ايضا
شخص ولغه موجوده ومكتوبه وايضا من خلال
ايضا الاشخاص الذين يدربوا على هذه اللغه
بامكانهم ايضا التحدث مع هؤلاء المعتمرين
لكي يتم عمليه تسهيل خروجهم وايضا عبورهم
ليس فقط في عمليه تسهيل العبور وكذلك
الخروج ولكن ايضا في عمليه تسهيل مهامهم
ايضا داخل صحن المطاف او ايضا في المسعى
طبعا اليوم الرئاسه الحرم او رئاسه حرم
المكي تسعى بان يكون
في خلال شهر رمضان ان يصل عدد المعتمرين
اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين معتمر طبعا هذه
الخطه التشغيليه هي وضعت من اجلها هذا
العدد تحديدا وايضا هناك خطه ايضا اخرى
بديله في حاله زياده عدد الطاقه
الاستعابيه متى متى سنه الظروف الخارجيه
والمحيطه بالحرم المكي من خلال الخدمات او
اضافه زياده في عدد الخدمات سواء الخدمات
الصحيه او كذلك الخدمات التي المقدمه
للمعتمرين طبعا هذا هو الحال من خلال
الكاميرا التي نرصدها وما زلنا نقوم
بالمرور او انتهاء من شوط بالقرب من
انتهاء شوط مع المعتمرين من خلال وقوفنا
او بالقربنا من الحجر الاسود ونحن الان قد
امضينا قرابه الدقيقتين ونصف ونحن بالقرب
يعني بمعنى ذلك ان خلال الدقيقتين ونصف
بامكان الحاج ان يطوف شوطا واحدا في صحن
المطاف طبعا اليوم نتحدث عن اربع ادوار
ايضا اخرى بامكان ايضا المعتمرين
استخدامها وهذه الكاميرا ايضا الان كاميرا
العربيه ترصد الوضع الداخلي لي ايضا عدد
من الذين يقومون بالتوافي الدور الثاني من
الحرم المكي ومسجد او بتحديدا من مسجد
الحرام ونشاهدهم وايضا نشاهد عدد من
المعتبرين الذين يقومون بالنزول والخروج
من السلالم خصصت
لعمليه خروجهم ودخولهم اثناء انتهاء من
المطاف وايضا ممن يرغبون بالدخول الى صحن
المطاف لاتمام عمليه طوافي شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا من الحرم المكيه الشريف مراسل العربيه
هاني صفيه
في السعوديه تنطلق اليوم حمله منصه جود
الاسكان الخيريه لتامين المساكن للاسر
لاشد احتياجا للمسكن تحت عنوان حمله
اكتتاب جود الاسكان الخيري الحملات تستهدف
بطبيعتها المجتمع بكافه مؤسسات وافراده في
تامين مبلغ مليار ريال لتامين ما يصل الى
3500 مسكن للاسر شديده الحاجه وتقوم فكره
الحمله على محاكاه فكره سوق الاسهم الا
انها لا تخضع لعوائد ماديه انما لعوائده
خيريه مجتمعيه باسهم تبلغ 100 مليون سهم
في رابعه بعد قليل
ترقب كبير لعوده مسلسل طاش ما طاش ثنائيات
القصب والسدحان تعود بعد 11 عاما من
الانقطاع
[موسيقى]
لمواجهه الصين وروسيا تكشف عن التوجه
واشنطن لتعزيز ترسانتها في اسيا واوروبا
لقاء سعودي ايراني مرتقب وامير عبداللهيان
يؤكد حصه طهران على تطوير العلاقات مع
الرياض
اول ايام رمضان خطه تشغيليه ضخمه في مكه
107 الاف معتمر طاقه الحرم في الساعه
حادثه الشاب في الرياض تعيد التحذيرات
للواجهه ادمانه سريع والتعافي من اعراضه
صعب
وتركب واسع على عوده مسلسل طاش ثنائيه
القصر والسدحان تعود بعد 11 عاما من
الانقطاع
اهلا بكم من جديد ماذا الشاب والمخدر لا
تزال وراء الكثير من الجرائم البشعه
وحالات العنف في السعوديه مع ملاحظه تزايد
اقبال فئات معينه على تعاطيها انتشر مؤخرا
مقطع فيديو لمواطن سعودي يعتدي على رجل
امن ذكرت الجهات الامنيان المواطنه قبض
عليه وهو تحت تاثير تعاطي ماده الشبو
المخدره
هلوسه وسلوك عدواني وجرائم بشعه خارجه عن
المالوف كلها ارتبطت في الاونه الاخيره
ارتباطا وثيقا بمتعاطى ماده الشبو في هذا
المقطع متعاطي لماده الشبو يعتدي على رجل
امن اثناء عمليه ضبطه بعد ان اعتدى على
عائلته وهددهم بالسكين في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض لكن قد لا يمر وقت طويل
حتى ينتشر مقطع مصور يشبه هذا او اعنف
يوثق جريمه صادمه لمتعاطي الشبو او مشهد
تمثيلي تبثه الجهات المعنيه يروي قصه
حقيقيه لمتعاطي الشبو وهو ينفذ جريمته
والتي كان منها حرق متعاطين لبيت العائله
ليقتل والده ووالده واخوته جرائم جعلت
الجهات المعنيه بمكافحه المخدرات تقوم
بحملات توعويه عن خطر هذه الماده والتي
باتت منتشره في الاونه الاخيره وتحديدا
بين اوساط المراهقين والشباب
ما هي ماده الشبو هي ماده كيميائيه لها
نتائج مدمره على الجهاز العصبي المركزي
للانسان والجهاز المناعي هذه الماده تصيب
متعاطيها باعراض نفسيه منها السلوك
العدواني والشعور بالقلق وفقدان القدرات
العقليه والاكتئاب الشديد والهلوسه
الطب النفسي وعلاج الادمان الدكتور محمد
المقهوي دكتور محمد حياك الله معي في نشره
الرابعه دكتور كل عام وانت طيب مشهدناه في
الفيديو الاخير يعني الو بالفعل هل من
اثار تعاطي هذه الماده ماده الشبو بمعنى
انه الانسان الذي يتعطى اتعاطى هذه الماده
هل يصل في رده الفعل ربما الى مواجهه رجال
الامن كمنشاهدنا في الصوره
الكريم الامر الاخر اشكركم على تسليه
الضوء على هذا الموضوع ربما الموضوع ماده
الشبو طرح كثيرا في الفتره الاخيره ومهما
يطرح ومهما يتكلم عنه تتظل الحاجه الملحه
جدا جدا ما شاهدناه هذا الفيديو او من كسر
من مقاطع في العمل الاخيره تقريبا بحكم
عملنا في مجال الادمان في مستشفيات اراده
والصحه النفسيه نشاهد اعظم من الحوادث
اعظم من هذه الحالات ماده التشابه كما ذكر
في التقرير هي ماده كيميائيه وهي ماده
طبعا مصنعه ولها عده ولها عده
مسميات الشبو والكريستال
وغيره هذه الماده تشتغل على النواقع
العصبيه وبالذات ماده الدوبامين وتؤثر على
نقاط معينه في الدماغ خاصه
الجبهي الامامي هذا الفصل مسؤول عن اتخاذ
القرارات بمعنى ان الشخص عندما يتخذ قرار
هل هذا قرار صحيح ولا خاطئ هل بامكاني ان
اقدم على هذا الفعل او لا هناك منطق في
الدماغ تحدد هذا الامر للاسف
من يستخدمون ماده الشبو يفقدون القدء هذه
القدره
فتصبح قدراتك على اتخاذ القرارات والحكم
على الامور وتقييمها وتقييم العواقب صفر
فنجدهم فنجد من يقتل من يعتدي على رجال
الامن من يعتدي على الاسره الحوادث التي
سمعناها من قاموا باحراق الاسر من يعتدي
على نفسه
ومره علينا حالات تقدموا على الانتحار
بسبب تعاطيهم لماده الشبوب
تاثيرها الان بهذا الشكل على المتعاطي
دكتور محمد
طبعا
في نبضات القلب همم
تاثيرها على الاسنان ممكن الوفاء بسبب
السكته القلبيه والمرحله حالات بسبب جرعه
الزائده لماده الشبو طبعا عندهم سكته
قلبيه وتوفوا في اللحظه ولا زلنا نشاهد
تاثيرات تظهر مع الاونه الاخيره خاصه ان
هذه الماده كونها ماده مصنعه فكثير فكثير
من المواد المصنعه يدخل فيها مواد اليها
مواد اخرى كما عمل في احد المختبرات الذين
في المنطقه الشرقيه عندما قاموا بتحليل
ماده الشبو وجدوا ان هناك مواد مضافه على
هذه الماده تجعلها اكثر خطوره هذه من
الناحيه الجسديه من الناحيه النفسيه
العصبيه
الانفعال التهور الاكتئاب احيانا قد يصل
الاكتئاب الى درجه شديد تصل به الى
الانتحار ايضا
او بصريه ومن اشد الاعراض التي نلاحظها
عند البعض ما يسمى بالظلالات وهي عباره عن
افكار تكون عندك شرط وهي غير حقيقيه مثلا
يعتقد ان والله هناك اشخاص يراقبون اشخاص
تريدون ان يضرونا
فبالتالي بسبب هذه الافكار تكون لديه
الجراه على الاعتداء على الاخرين اذا عنده
فكره ان فلان يراقبني عليه فلان والله
يريد ان يضرني فانه
يعتدي عليه اعتقاد منه انه يحمي نفسه من
هذا الامر اضافه الى اضطرابات النفسيه
الاخرى كالقلق ونبات الهلع وغيرها كيف
شايفين الدكتور حجم انتشار هذه الماده
الان ماده الشبو في السعوديه
والله الى قبل تقريبا
خمس سنوات كان كانت نسبه قليله جدا الان
في الاونه الاخيره نلاحظ تصاعد كبير في
هذه المره طبعا عده اسباب اولا سهوله
تصنيعها الامر الاخر
رخص ثمن هذه الماده
وايضا بعض متعاقين الشاب وفي الغالب
متعاطى الشاب لا يريد بماده يبدا بمواد
اخرى او ما يسمى
الحبوب المنشطه في ظل
قله هذه الحبوب او هذه الماده بدا البعض
يتوجه الى استخدام ماده التشبه لاحظنا على
المثال بعض المراجعين في العياده بعض
الذين انتقلوا ماده الشبوه عندما سالناهم
قال بسبب والله الكبتاجون غير متوفره
ارتفع سعره فبدا بعضهم التوجه الى ماده
التشابه طبعا ماده الشبو تعطي نفس تاثير
ماده الكبتاجون او الحبوب المنشطه ولكن
بما يعادل خمسه او سبعه اضعاف في الشده
والاثار المدمره كيف يجب ان نتعامل مع
المتعاطي لماده الشبو ومتى ممكن الانسان
يدمنها يعني بعد اول جرعه
بعض الحالات قد تدمي من الجرعه الاولى بعض
الحالات طبعا هذه حالات قليله لكن البعض
قد يحتاج لعده استخدامات حتى يكون مدمن
لهذه الماده هذا الامر الاول الامر الثاني
في التعامل اولا نحذر من التعامل مع مدمن
الشبوب في حال
مثل ما قلنا بعض الامهات والاباء يعتقد
انه سيحاول ان يستعطف هذا الشخص واحنا
اهلك وبطل ووقف في حاله تعاطف هو غير مدرك
بتصرفاتك وافعاله واقواله فننتظر حتى يحدث
يتجاوب ومع
الاسف فيبدا فيكون الحال باخذ الى احد
المصحات العلاجيه
للصحه النفسيه في حال عدم التجاوب
هنا تقول اسره مضطره للعلاج القسري وهناك
وزاره الصحه بالتعاون مع اداره مكافه
المخدرات ووفروا ما يسمى بالعلاج القصري
من خلال الاتصال على رقم واحد تسعه خمسه
خمسه ورفع بلاغ يتم التنسيق مع المكافحه
واخذ هذا الشخص الى المصحه للعلاج ولا
يترتب على هذا اي جرعات امنيه لو بلغنا
عليه قد يسجن قد والله يفطر في حكم السجن
او الاحكام مرتبطه في حاله انه انا كان
هناك اعتداء او وراء على الاخرين لكن اذا
كان التواصل من اجل العلاج يتم توفيرها
بموانتها السريه طيب بعد العلاج القسري بس
في ماده الشبوه ولا في كل المواد وهل
الاسلوب بطريقه العلاج تختلف بين متعاطي
الشبوه غيرها من المواد دكتور سريعا
بالنسبه للعلاج القصري هو يشمل جميع
المواد الحشيشه ركون والكحول وغيرها من
المواد الامر الثاني بالنسبه لطريقه
العلاج تقريبا اغلب البرامجيه
[موسيقى]
نعود مره اخرى لمتابعه ما يجري الان في
فرنسا من احتجاجات كبيره ضد قانون التقاعد
من باريس سانضم او تنضم الينا مراسله
العربيه زين عدي زينه مرحبا بك زينة ما
الذي يجري الان في باريس
تحياتي نحن في ساحه البستيف في باريس حيث
انطلقت التظاهره منذ حوالي اكثر منذ حوالي
اكثر من اكثر من نصف ساعه كما ترون
التظاهره الى الان اجواء طبيعيه لكن في
بطن اخرى كارين ونانسي هناك عنف بين
المتظاهرين وبين الشرطه الى الان التظاهره
ستنطلق من هذه الساحه في اتجاه ساحه
الاوبرا وقد تنتهي عند الساعه السابعه
مساء بالنسبه لليوم هو يوم الخميس الاسود
كما اطلق عليه النقابات اليوم المتوقع بان
تكون التظاهرات عنيفه الى الان بحسب
النقابات هناك 240 240 نقطه 240 نقطه
بالنسبه للتظاهرات
بان اليوم سيكون حاسما لان فرنسا تنتظر
هذا اليوم لانه اليوم الاول بعد ان اقر
لتجمع التظاهرات بعد
خروج بعد ان اقر هذا القانون قانون رفع سن
التقاعد الى 64 عاما المتظاهرون اليوم
غاضبون من خطاب ماكرون في الامس اعتبروا
بان ماكرون لم لم يسمع صوتهم ولن يغير
شيئا
خطابه في الامس الان التظاهرات لا تكتفي
فقط هنا في هذه الساحه هناك تجمعات عديده
في مناطق اخرى من هنا في العاصمه
المتظاهرون حاولوا ان يقتحموا مطار شاردو
غولا في صباح اليوم ودخلوا عليه وكان هناك
صعوبات للمسافرين في الدخول الى المطار
ايضا في محطه قطار غاردو اليوم هنا في
باريس دخل اليها المتظاهرون ومنعوا
القطارات من الحركه والتنقل مظاهر
الاحتجاج واسعه او الغضب نرى المشهد اكثر
صوره من خلفك
ساحه الباستين
الاعداد كبيره كما ترون هي اليوم من
المتوقع ان تكون اكبر من السابق الاعداد
ان تكون اكبر من السابق متوقع ان يكون في
باريس وحدها 40 الف الى ستين الف من
متظاهر بينما في كافه انحاء فرنسا من
المتوقع ان ترسل الاعداد الى 800 الف هذه
هي الاعداد المتوقعه ايضا من قبل السلطات
الفرنسيه بالنسبه لاحدى مراكز الشرطه في
في مدينه
تعرضت لدخول المحتجين
واذان رئيس
ادانا وزير الداخليه هذا العنف الذي قام
به المتظاهرون والاعتداء على مركز الشرطه
في لوريوم الى الان واضح بان التظاهرات
ستكون عنيفه
ولكن النقابات حاولت ان لكن النقابات
حاولت ان تطلب من المتظاهرين ان يتجنبوا
العنف وان تكون هناك تظاهرات سلميه لكنهم
لا نعتقد بانهم يستطيعون السيطره على
الارض بشكل كامل هناك تظاهرات عشوائيه
وعفويه غالبا لا تكون مرتبطه بالنقابات
بشكل مباشر
شكرا جزيلا لك زينا عدي مراسله العربيه من
باريس
خلف البلوي سعودي في عامه المئه قضى منها
ثلاثين عاما راميا المدفع رمضان في مدينه
حائل في شمال السعوديه زميل جزاع التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
خط تدريب بالرياض على المدافع
كيف رميها كيفها
[موسيقى]
صرت انا فزت على هالمجموعه هذه كلها
اخذته اول واحد ناجح
[موسيقى]
بعد رحله التدريب هذه اسندت مهمه رامي
مدفع قلعه عرس في مدينه حائل للعمل خلف
البلوي الذي حمل على عاتقه اعلان وقت
الافطار والامساك للصيام طيله 30 عاما
ليله رمضان سبع مدافع
احتفال بالبنغال
سبع مدافع
يعني انه دخل
وبعدين
النبات يعني
يتسحرون مدفعي
وعلى الفجر واحد مدفع
بالفطور طلقه
هذا العام يكمل العم خلف البلوي عامه
المئه قضى منها ثلاثه عقود راميه اللي
مدفع رمضان ما يفسر العلاقه الوطيده
بينهما رغم الضرر الذي عايشه البلوي خصوصا
في حاسه السمع فوق ثلاث سنه
يوم يسور ذلك تشدد وتسمح
[موسيقى]
وني من المستشفى
اوراق مبلوله
يحطونها بذلك برضو
اذا سار المدفع
راسي
[موسيقى]
ينتفخافه شويه ولكن يبقى ويرجع الى يومنا
هذا وبعدين عقوه في المجمع ما حطوا واحد
من مدينه حائل
جزاعا معصي العربيه
عند السابع بتوقيت رياضه ترقب بالسعوديون
عوده المسلسل الشهير طاشمان طاش وثنائيات
ناصر القصبي وعبد الله السدحان بعد انقطاع
وغياب منذ عام 2012
[موسيقى]
من ركبنا ابو محمد اغنيه ومشاهد ارتبطت
بذاكره السعوديين طوال 18 عاما مضت ثنائيه
القصب والسدحان تعود في طاش العوده بعد 11
عاما من الغياب
هلا هلا
بالليله الخافت ترحيب وترقب بين اوساط
السعوديين بهذه العوده للمسلسل الذي بقي
خالدا في ذاكره السعوديين لعقود
اطلقها وقت ما تشوف الدرب
بنات الحمايل
افكار جريئه طرحها المسلسل الشهير في
مواسمه السابقه الا ان التساؤلات تدور حول
هذه النسخه من طاش الفنان السعودي ناصر
القصبي اكد ان طاش العوده سيشهد استرجاعا
لبعض الشخصيات والافكار التي طرحت سابقا
تركترات اللي عندنا يعني ايضا بدينا نرجع
بعضها مش كلها حاولنا ايضا انه يكون اغلب
الممثلين اللي اللي
ساهموا معنا في طاش للاسف في الافكار هي
اللي تحدد انت وين تتحرك وتختار مين وايضا
بعد انقطاع
والانقطاع طويل يعني اكثر من عشر سنوات
ما التقينا في عمل
فالناس حتكون مبسوطه انها تشوف اثنين
ارتبطوا معهم في فتره من الفترات انهم لما
يرجعون شو بيقدمون يعني عشرون حلقه فقط
عمر طاش العوده تاتي في ظل تغييرات كبيره
في صناعه الدراما السعوديه والتغييرات
الاكبر في ثقافه المجتمع وقضاياه التي لم
تعد كما كانت عليه
اذا وقع القمر بجانب الثريا في اليوم
الثالث من الشهر الهجري فهو دلال على
بدايه نهايه الربيع تفاصيل مع خالد في
تقويم
[موسيقى]
اجمل النجوم الثريا واجمل ما بالكون القمر
واذا اجتمع جمالين الجمال الكوني مع جمال
النجوم قال العامه القمر جارا الثريا
فالمقارنه معناها الاجتماع فاذا وقع القمر
بجانب الثريه في اليوم الثالث من الشهر
الهجري فهذا اماره وعلامه على بدايه
انصراف الربيع وانتهائه والعامه يقولون
جراند ثالث ربيعا
رف
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والثريا احد منازل القمر الشهيره والمنازل
هي المحطات التي يستريح بها القمر اثناء
رحلته الشهريه حول الارض واهم الاقترانات
سته اثنين شتوي واثنين الربيعي واثنين
صيفي والاقتران الثالث اول الاقترانات
الصيفيه ولهذا العرب قالوا اذا ما قارن
القمر الثريا لثالثهم فقد ذهب الشتاء
[موسيقى]
ختم رابع بالعناوين
لمواجهه الصين وروسيا تكشف عن توجه واشنطن
لتعزيز ترسانتها في اسيا واوروبا
لقاء سعودي ايراني مرتقب وامير عبدالغه ان
يؤكد حرص طهران على تطوير العلاقات مع
الرياض
اول ايام رمضان خطه تشغيليه ضخمه في مكه
المكرمه 7000 معتمر طاقه الحرم فزع
وحادثه تشاب في الرياض تعيد التحضيرات
للواجهه اتمامه سريع والتعافي من اعراضه
صعب
لعوده بمسلسل طاش ثنائيه القصب والسدحان
تعود بعد احد عشر عاما من الانقطاع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]